[Music]
you
I'm working with other members of
parliament now and change UK are you
seeing your own opinions changing
working with Labour MPs no because that
change had already happened then I'd
work with chakram you know and Chris
Leslie for nearly three years now since
the referendum I've got to know chuck
ordering the referendum and then
obviously afterwards you know this it
hacks me off a bit that people say oh
you all need to work together while
we've been chipping working together for
the last three years we've not talked
about it very much because a lot of it
has been very quiet we just get on and
do it and noticeably on brexit the level
of cross-party working it has been it
has been incredible and if people knew
the trust that there has been so there's
a whatsapp group that I can think of
which represents every single plan every
single political party is in this group
part of the brexit party because it's a
parliamentary political parties it's
never leaked never leaked it's got
Tory's labour plied SNP Caroline Lucas
to obviously change labour we're all on
it and we speak very freely and we work
together in relation to brexit never
linked and I think that says everything
so is it actually an example of a really
good time or healthy time for politics
no it's a really [ __ ] time in politics
actually I think so doing hayek
supporting what's going on there's awful
beauty parade of all these dreadful hard
brexit ears you know do you just it's
just going to be a question of time
before it gets really dirty and nasty
and there'll be a lot of that
dog-whistle type politics pandering to
what is now shrinking electorate of the
Conservative Party but it's and that the
membership has changed because it's been
infiltrated by a lot of old you kippers
and you've got people who will who's
going to be the most right-wing that's
how they you know that's how they're
going to win that election who can be
the hardest brexit here the most
irresponsible grexit here and who can
pander the most of the right-wing that's
taken over the Tory party I think that's
pretty appalling
and as I say in the meantime the real
problems that we should be looking at I
just gained she's not being done so
where's this green paper on social care
it's all well and good the government
and I congratulate for putting an extra
twenty billion pounds into the NHS which
it needed of course but it's you know we
just keep throwing money at it
which is almost soaking up the or
dealing with the mess but we're not
actually solving the many of the
problems which is one about how we make
sure that we look but people look after
themselves better and we prevent a lot
of illnesses and people getting sick in
the first place and of course the other
huge piece of work which we still
haven't done is hook up Social Care in
the NHS and the situation with too many
older people who are not getting the
proper social care and the health care
that they need
means that there is this huge amount of
the NHS was just mopping it all up
whereas actually we should be investing
because you know we know what the
population is going to do that's the one
thing we can predict how long people are
going to live the sort of illnesses and
diseases they'll be living with and yet
we're not putting into place the sort of
stuff that we should be to be able to
mitigate a lot of that and actually stop
older people having to go to the
hospital in the first place because
their be properly looked at in either
their care home or in their home so
there's masses of work that's got to be
done and nobody's doing it for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you